i woke up today like nothing was wrong
emily mitchell has died the parenting
blogger
and influencer was 36
and she was 16 weeks pregnant with her
fifth child
according to a gofundme page set up for
her family
emily died unexpectedly on december
22nd okay we finished our first half of
the day of school
and it went really great i feel really
encouraged um joe gave them a speech
last night about not giving me any
trouble so
it worked emily leaves behind her
husband
joe and four children finn
isla eddie and lulu the description
on the fundraising page states quote our
hearts are broken
and her joyful presence will be greatly
missed by
so many m made a big impact in so many
people's lives
and this loss is incomprehensible for
anyone who knew her
our friend was a dedicated mom and wife
she had a heart for the lord and loved
her children
so dearly emily's instagram page the
hidden way
chronicled her family's life on a farm
and homeschooling their four children
you and coco are doing what you're
watching you're watching the clouds
okay you need to get back in and finish
your math and then you may be free
as of sunday the gofundme initiative has
raised over
160 thousand dollars
the organizer posted an update on
january 1st
that reads quote thank you so much for
all of your support
her family was surprised by the
outpouring of love
from her homeschool community on
instagram
together we went above and beyond to
support them
and even though this will not take away
their pain
we know this gift means a lot to them
thank you
[Music]
always
you